Coleman Mariana eels Mira what sets this
inquiry apart Louise Healey is that it
examines events that have hugely
impacted each and every one of us
William Roy Edwards but some families
more than others
Kim Nutt lost her husband to covid
ambulance driver Paul Paul Nutt
the girls my other daughter as well
begged him not to go to work because
they were worried about his safety and
he said the guidance says what I have to
do and I'll adhere to it and I'll be
safe
and it really wasn't God this was wrong
the guidance was totally wrong
at that time Paul was told he didn't
need to wear a mask it was the
testimonies of families that opened the
inquiry with a video played to the room
I said can you try and
call us then if you know you can if this
time to get us up there we don't want to
die alone she was only 54.
and she died alone
five days after my dad
the scope of this inquiry is immense
from the political decisions that were
made when the virus arrived to the
long-term impact on the Health Service
but this first round of evidence looks
at whether we could and should have been
better prepared even at this stage
before hearing the evidence
it is apparent that we might not have
been very well prepared at all the
council to the inquiry told the chair
lady Hallett that previous
administrations may have fallen short
following the Ebola outbreak it was
right that the G7 devoted significant
time to how best to try and prevent a
future Global pandemic
that despite this pledge from David
Cameron there was a failure to consider
the need for Mass testing or how to
protect the vulnerable there was a
blinkered focus on the likelihood of a
flu pandemic and anyway resilience plans
were consumed by preparations for brexit
the families expect the evidence will
show a lack of responsibility in
government for civil emergency
preparedness
with little or no ministerial leadership
and a chaos of committees which led to
poor planning and ultimately a reactive
rather than proactive response to the
virus and the association of directors
of Public Health confirmed it was
chaotic at the start of the pandemic
directors were learning about new
policies and guidance at the same time
as members of the public were when the
televised 5 PM daily briefings began to
be broadcast
these are the details families want to
know what do you want to come out of
this inquiry the truth and what actually
happened we need to know about the
decisions that were made why they were
made or why they weren't made so that we
can hopefully learn the lessons to
prevent anything like this happening
again inquiry is expected to last more
than three years Jason Farrell Sky News